les promesses brisées
sur nos élections passées alors que
certains pensent maintenant en vacances
aujourd'hui l'heure est au bilan
[Musique]
les leçons je m'excuserai pas de prendre
la meilleure décision pour les Québécois
est adopté on est en plein inflation les
jours de la misère à arriver et on va se
voter à nous-mêmes 30000 dollars les
erreurs David Johnston est un homme
irréprochable les moments forts des six
derniers mois il est démissionné tels
que demander par le motion du mpd3 mois
avec ces terres giversations avec le
manque de leadership du Premier ministre
des politiciens ont brillé on verra qui
a fait quoi et qui devrait peut-être pas
faire quoi la prochaine fois c'est très
forme elle va contribuer à changer la
donne pour l'avenir du français d'autres
ont déçu c'est une maman très difficile
pour les Canadiens j'ai pris un
engagement
pas en mesure de le livrer et regarde
sur les réformes promises à Québec et
que faut-il surveiller des élections
partielles à Ottawa ici Daniel Thibault
dimanche 11 juin bienvenue à cette
émission spéciale des coulisses du
pouvoir notre bilan de fin de saison
[Musique]
mesdames messieurs bon dimanche qui a
bien fait qui va préférer oublier les
derniers mois sur qui ou sur quoi
devrions-nous garder un œil d'ici la fin
de l'année tant que question suscité par
les 6 derniers mois étant de répondre
potentielle aussi et qui de mieux que
nos trois panéhéistes pour offrir
quelques pistes de réflexion et
aujourd'hui sont avec nous comme on en a
pris l'habitude de à cette fin d'année
Alex Chantal Michel merci d'être là
d'entendre vos commentaires vos pistes
de réflexion on va lancer cette
discussion là dans quelques minutes mais
d'abord on va acheter un oeil sur les
événements qui ont retenu la tension sur
la scène politique fédérale et
provinciale au cours des 6 derniers mois
les Canadiens entamment dans une
économie en plein tumulte on est là pour
aider les gens de façon ciblée
les syndicats veulent amortir le choc et
réclament des hausses de salaire pendant
11 jours 155 000 fonctionnaires fédéraux
feront la grève une première en 30 ans
nous avons une qui est juste qui est
raisonnable
au Québec aussi le secteur public exige
les augmentations pendant que les
négociations s'étirent les élus eux
octroy une hausse de 30%. tu comprends
vraiment les job d'enseignante à la job
de député l'autre est en train de me
dire que
çaville à faire accepter la réforme
qu'il souhaite imposer au système
d'éducation
nous allons résister à la résistance au
changement c'est pas compliqué
un début de seconde mandat difficile
pour le gouvernement logo marqué d'abord
par le départ à mi-mandat de la PDG
d'Hydro-Québec
ont pu savoir et divergences les choses
peuvent exister mais c'est pour ça qu'il
fait que je quitte marqué aussi par des
promesses brisées je vais quand même
rappeler que François Legault avait mis
son siège en jeu sur les maternelles 4
ans marquez surtout par des volte-faces
on n'a pas de données qui justifierait
l'implantation d'un tunnel autoroutier
on propose en fait des modifications
importantes de tous nos programmes
d'immigrations économiques
et un virage numérique difficile parce
qu'on a suffisamment informé la
population la réponse à cette question
là c'est non clairement pas autre virage
majeur celui que souhaite imposer
Christian Dubé au réseau québécois de la
santé notre objectif c'est justement de
décentraliser le réseau les provinces
réclament d'Ottawa 280 milliards de
dollars sur 10 ans pour corriger les
lacunes exposées par la pandémie le
gouvernement Trudeau n'offrira
finalement que 46 milliards ça ne règle
pas le problème fondamental du
financement des soins de santé
vous avez devant vous un premier du
Québec qui est heureux les bonnes
nouvelles se font rares jusqu'à la
visite de Joe Biden ce soir à minuit
enfin le chemin Roxane va être fermé
Ottawa les contrats de la firmeckenzie
la nomination des mirats agawabi pour
lutter contre l'islamophobie place le
gouvernement Trudeau sur la défensive
ces propos à l'endroit du Québec à
l'endroit de la nation québécoise sont
complètement inacceptables en février 4
ballons dans le ciel nord-américain
ravive les tensions entre Ottawa et
pick-up ça représentait une menace
raisonnable
à la sécurité des de l'aviation civile
l'influence de la Chine ici préoccupe
Justin Trudeau était au courant de cette
ingérence des parties de position
réclament d'une enquête publique à
partir de d'ingérence réussie dans
combien de circonscriptions en
intervient une 5 12 14 juste un Trudeau
choisit plutôt de confier le dossier à
DVD Johnston il y aura un rapporteur
spécial indépendant qui se chargera de
déterminer les prochaines étapes un
choix qui est loin de faire l'unanimité
il a nommé une amie et une voisin de son
chalet et membre de la Fondation de Kudo
surtout que l'ex gouverneur général
rejette l'idée d'une enquête publique
l'examen publique de l'enseignement
classique et tout simplement impossible
face au concert de critiques incapable
de calmer la donne David jonesston
annonce finalement qu'il ne terminera
pas son mandat c'était la seule chose à
faire c'est maintenant autour de
Monsieur Trudeau de respecter de votre
parlementaire et mettre en place une
enquête publique nous avons pas écarté
aucune option en pleine tourmente le
gouvernement Trudeau obtient tout de
même quelques victoires un meilleur
contrôle des armes dérègle pour les
géants numériques une Loi sur les
langues officielles modernisée soyons
clair la seule langue qui est menacée au
Canada c'est le français
j'ai décidé de me retirer de mon rôle de
député de Notre-Dame de Grâce westmalt
et pendant que les départs de margarnot
derenotto impose des élections et une
mise à jour de la Sainte politique dame
nature elle impose au gouvernement de
nouveaux défis on va faire face à de
plus en plus d'événements
météorologiques extrêmes qui vont être
de plus en plus cher en couple pour
notre pays après les tempêtes le verglas
les inondations les feux de forêt qui
ont déjà dévasté des millions d'hectares
d'un bout à l'autre du pays annonce un
été particulièrement difficile dans
l'histoire de la Sauveur il est presque
50 dernières années la pire année on le
dépassé à ce moment si on veut
s'assurer que tout soit éteint on a pour
l'été
[Musique]
Chantal mais si vous demandez aux
électeurs ils vont plutôt vous parler
surtout au Québec des virages en épingle
du gouvernement faut quand même le faire
Détrier élu et si bref échéance et on
parle pas d'une petite promesse et je
vous dirai la réforme électorale de
Justin Trudeau est une promesse forme et
c'était une petite promesse mais le
troisième lien l'immigration c'est des
gros dossiers
est-ce que moi je trouve intéressant de
ces événements marquants là c'est que
élu ou réélu à peu près dans la même
période le gouvernement Ford au
contraire mis la au max pour
réaliser ses promesses monsieur Ford
sentier moins bien que François
belle comparaison de le voir comme ça
mais effectivement les deux les deux
premiers ministres ont pris vraiment des
approches différentes là-dessus avec
vous retenez quoi à vous des six
premiers mois 2023 sur le troisième lien
entre Québec et les vies parce que
c'était aussi la première fois vraiment
que le caucus de François Legault était
testé sur leur solidité François Legault
qui est le fondateur du parti tout le
monde a toujours suivi très populaire et
là pour la première fois on sentait de
la grogne de la tension des ministres
des députés qui sortaient en disant on
n'est pas très content on est une
famille unie mais on n'est pas très
content riche c'est aussi
s'excuse au bord des larmes et donc vrai
première crise interne à gérer depuis
que la carte est au pouvoir la question
c'est ce que ça va laisser des traces
électréralement parlant sur la réussite
de Québec on pensait que ça donnerait
peut-être le petit coup de fouet qu'il
faut à iriduel peut-être pas finalement
et on n'a pas l'impression qu'il y en a
profité tant que ça ça fragilité et
fragilisé certains de ces ministres
entre autres donc oui ça a été quand
même un gros un gros gros virement de
situation pour un projet qu'on avait
défendu quand même bec et Hong depuis
pas mal d'années bien avant que la
claque sur le pouvoir ça doit être 2014
des deux plateformes électorales de
Monsieur le
alors que peut-être que dans deux ans
deux ans et demi ça aurait été le chef
qu'on pense à remplacer alors il est
encore en position de force
effectivement alors ça aussi un autre
élément qui est retenu l'attention la
plus grande
erreur commise depuis le début de
l'année Michel c'est un lien avec moi ma
première réponse c'est de ne pas avoir
déclenché la quête publique parce qu'une
enquête publique c'est pas juste pour
aller au fond d'une chose c'est aussi
pour enlever le débat de la scène
politique de l'essai l'enquête faire le
travail et ça monsieur Trudeau ne semble
pas l'avoir compris la nomination de
Monsieur Johnston après ça la décision
encore incompréhensible à mon avis de
Monsieur Johnson de rester là malgré un
vote de nos conférences du Parlement
fait que c'est une bonne politique qui
reste dans le décor et qui pour raient
suivre le gouvernement jusqu'à
l'élection et qui peut être la grenade
depuis des goupillers ensemble n'importe
quoi qui va faire que ça va exploser et
il faut pas s'entendre à ce que les
Chinois cessent du jour au lendemain
tout est gérance politique
de la maison
alors
et donc de la grenade des coups de pied
c'est une très bonne analogie vous êtes
tous à peu près sur la même longueur
d'onde
comme rapporteur spécial c'est demander
au début si c'était pas un bon choix il
est pas associé au libéraux
particulièrement c'est un choix comme
gouverneur général de
steveneurs la Fondation un peu mais je
ne pense pas d'ailleurs qu'il soit aussi
près personnellement que les parties
d'opposition le laisse entendre juste
intrudo quand un chalet à 55 km de
distance on peut pas vraiment dire que
c'est des voisins de chalet en tout cas
pas dans la définition que moi j'ai
d'être des voisins de chalets mais
visiblement de la manière dont ensuite
qui le défendu son rapport qui ne
recommandait pas d'enquête publique
comme le disait Michel là on a vu que
c'était peut-être finalement pas un si
bon choix c'est la manière de se
défendre lorsqu'il est passé en comité
parlementaire il y avait beaucoup de
trous dans son argumentaire donc le fait
qu'il ne fasse pas autorité pour quelque
chose d'aussi controversé que de ne pas
déclencher une enquête publique
visiblement on n'a pas c'était pas la
bonne personne pour s'occuper de ça et
je vais partir du choix parce que quand
on fait le choix on sait pas tout ça et
donc je vais dire l'erreur c'est de
Justin Trudeau de pas avoir ayant vu les
recommandations de début de Johnston de
pas avoir dit merci mais pour que cette
recommandation de zéro enquête publique
parle il faut que tu te fasses que la
suite se soit quelqu'un d'autre parce
que ou de lui dire quantalement voté
c'est quand même quelque chose la voix à
l'unanimité de quatre formations
politiques d'opposition à la Chambre des
communes qui disent qu'on a plus besoin
de tes services et il faudrait que tu
partes et juste un Trudeau non seulement
on choisit des Virgin mais après c'est
le garder et maintenant le défendu mais
il y aurait plus de défendre et pas le
garder il y aurait pu dire on sait on
sait parler c'est vraiment utile ce qui
m'a donné mais on a convenu tous les
deux que pour la suite des choses et
devant ce de passer au Parlement on va
essayer de trouver quelqu'un qui risque
de donner à plus de crédibilité même si
c'est injuste à l'exercice et la
performance en commission parlementaire
mais là Monsieur Johnson c'est pas aidé
parce que même les gens qui disent c'est
pas correct de le traiter comme ça
disent par contre c'était pas la
personne c'était pas l'homme de la
situation pour cette situation là je
suis désolé d'apprendre que mon chalet
qui était 50 km de chez
Alexis
au moins clarifier cette élément-là
je reste avec vous je suis en train de
la leçon la leçon politique a retenir
des six derniers mois
et là on revient à ce dossier de
l'ingérence chinoise qui a vu le
gouvernement Trudeau pour la première
fois d'ailleurs ils sont nuls en gestion
de crise c'est à dire toujours en mode
rattrapage si on avait nommé des vide
Johnson tout de suite à la place de
prendre deux semaines à se rendre compte
que ça allait pas s'en aller ça
nomination aurait eu ce régulaire
proactif si on avait dit Johnson ok tu
as recommandation pas d'enquête publique
mais en échange quelqu'un d'autre mais à
la place à chaque fois que le
gouvernement qui est en rattrapage
rattrapage rattrapage alors ils ont
jamais réussi à s'installer en avant tu
défilé et donc ils se font piétiner une
chance pour eux sur un dossier qui n'est
pas un dossier quotidien pour la
majorité des élections
des électeurs canadiens ne se soucie pas
de cette question là comme les gens dans
la bulle à Ottawa le fond je sais pas
combien de fois on vous en a
parlé c'est dur
là je veux
pas dire comme nous et personne
c'est pas une conversation d'avant après
souper de fin de semaine c'est jamais
abordé Michel votre leçon politique à
retenir les 2e mandats sont toujours
plus difficile que les premiers et quand
on revient sur une première électorale
que ce soit le troisième bien que ce
soit les seuils d'immigrations ça coûte
plus cher ça fait plus mal et il y a
tout ça d'autres projets qui étaient
ceux de du gouvernement de la CAQ les
espaces bleues c'est musées dans les
régions les maisons des années tout ça
est en train aussi de s'écrouler un peu
pour des questions de coup parfois pour
des questions d'opportunités d'autres
fois mais ça fait beaucoup de choses qui
portaient la signature de la coalition à
venir Québec qui ne marche plus et
ça c'est le genre de choses qui soit ça
arrive dans la première année du mandat
comme on est maintenant donné les gens
l'oublieront soit ça va devenir la
signature du deuxième mandat et là ça va
être long longtemps ici il y en a
d'autres les prochaines coûtent toujours
un petit peu plus cher à chaque fois un
peu plus compliqué à faire passer Elec
de son politique quand on veut aussi le
salaire des députés
avoir des arguments solides et oser les
défendre un peu et là on a l'impression
que le gouvernement de François Legault
lorsque vous lui aussi salade est
députés la seule chose que vous lui
faire c'est de la en parler le moins
possible d'ailleurs si mon Alain
barrette portait le projet de loi même
pas voter pour adopter son propre projet
de loi c'est pas rendu à l'Assemblée
nationale
il y avait toutes sortes de manière de
procéder autrement on aurait pu réviser
le fond de pension en même temps que
déjà été qualifié de Ferrari en disant
on va aussi ça va des députés mais on va
tamiser le fond de pension en échange on
peut créer un comité exécutoire qui va à
chaque fois se pencher là-dessus
la claque voulait aussi le salaire des
députés avait pas envie de défendre ce
projet-là ce qui fait que ça a été tout
proche puis à ce jour on regarde les
sondages puis les gens ne comprennent
pas pourquoi il faut aussi le salade et
députés de 30% au Québec il y a des
arguments qui existent
des gens qui pensent que les députés
étaient sous-payés qui avançait les
arguments que le gouvernement lui
n'osait même pas dire comme si on se
cachait puis ça passait pas très bien
dans l'opinion publique printemps de
vouloir hausser le salaire des députés
comme celle de Bernard drinville où on
compare la salade des enseignants à
celui des gens on est pris dans toutes
sortes
ça a l'air en fonction publique pour
régler encore
ça c'était ça c'était les événements le
son erreur c'est qu'elle après la pause
on va se pencher sur les performances
des politiciens comment s'en sont-ils
sortis en cette première moitié de 2023
réponse dans quelques minutes
[Musique]